I thought I knew
what a big movie was
until I came onto this
this movie for me existed
I'm getting a chance to tell a story that
I've been thinking about for quite a while
elementally for 20 years it's a story of a few
against many impossible odds good versus evil
I was really excited about Zach I just really
value and admire his enthusiasm for The Craft
a solid two months of preparing
the body to get to that place I
hadn't quite anticipated the
physical requirements of this
I've never trained that much
that much I just really wanted to make a giant
atmospheric and space adventure I mean it's
Gargantua it's so so so big so ambitious we get
to Traverse the darker corners of this universe
and it's only the beginning we'll
have a huge anticipation for this
film it's amazing something so
powerful that you just want more
Welcome back
everyone
it's Charlie Netflix dropped a trailer for
Rebel Moon showing a whole bunch of the movie
the characters so we'll break it all down we
finally know who most of the people are playing
and Zack Snyder's been talking about a lot he
said the movie actually started Life as a Star
Wars movie that he was going to make for lucasfilm
before he started doing all the Snyder verse of
movies back with Man of Steel Batman v Superman in
justice league if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos we'll
be getting more trailers pretty soon because the
movie's coming out at the end of this year and
Zack Snyder said since he moved on from Justice
League Snyder cut he's actually turning Rebel Moon
into a large franchise for Netflix so there'll be
spin-offs and a lot of other tie-in stuff that
he's developing too he already confirmed that
Rebel moon is going to be a two-part movie at
least his first one but he'll be doing more
movies in this universe after they haven't said
when Rebel Moon part 2 is coming out it's either
going to be next year or the year after that it
won't be that long it stars Charlie Hunnam hansu
Anthony Hopkins Sophia Boutella whole bunch of
familiar faces that you see like Ed Skrein velt
was a settlement known mostly for farming it's
where the hero Heroes of Rebel Moon started their
Journey when the Imperium arrived for their food
Ray Fisher was playing Darrian bloodaxe alongside
his sister Devra their low resource resistance
Fighters Charlie Hunnam is playing Kai he's a
mercenary Djimon Honsou's General Titus was an
Imperium general or former General who turned on
the world he once defended to live a sad life
fighting in a Coliseum his experience being a
general in their forces scarred him causing him
to leave and become a gladiator he was a former
Ally of Kora so when she's looking to defend velt
from the Imperium he's the first person that she
goes to Michiele huisman is playing Gunner he's
another farmer living on Belt that becomes part
of their resistance Carrie elways of all people
is playing the king of the Galactic Empire like
the king of the Imperium fra free is playing
the Regent balisarius he's the leader of the
Imperium Invasion Ed screen is playing the
Admiral Noble who's another leader in their
forces these really crazy looking people behind
them in these awesome costumes are called scribes
they're part of a religious group on the Imperium
Homeworld tasked with writing down the history of
the Galaxy within the universe of Rebel Moon they
called the imperium's Homeworld mother world but
a lot of the history that the scribes write down
is influenced by the politics of the Imperium so
they aren't always necessarily writing down the
true history of the Galaxy the shirtless dude
here with the crazy ABS is Tarik he was a member
of a noble family in the Imperium but after his
family had a run with Mother World Tara wound up
owing a life debt to a Rancher for whom he worked
as an indentured servant honor bound to see out
his debt so when Kora is going around trying to
recruit resistance Fighters he initially refuses
but eventually agrees to join them as you would
expect it looks like it's going to be super crazy
in a good way the movie's about a peaceful Colony
on the edge of the Galaxy that's threatened by the
armies of a tyrannical Regent named belisarius The
Desperate civilians dispatch a young woman who has
mysterious past to seek out Warriors from nearby
planets to help them challenge the region Anthony
Hopkins is playing Jimmy he's a robot knight this
character here and Sophia batella is playing
the titular Kora who's going around trying to
defend the plan it Netflix also just released
a teaser trailer for their live-action avatar
The Last Airbender I did a video for it so I'll
link it at the end of this but I don't think her
name Kora was inspired by Kora from The Legend
of Korra in the Avatar Universe the large ship
Landing seems like it belongs to the evil Regent
character if it wasn't clear when he's talking
about it it's actually a two-part movie like
this is just part one of Rebel Moon part two
will be a completely separate film that he's
working on later so I'm assuming there'll be
some kind of cliffhanger at the end of the first
movie This is actually Zack Snyder talking about
the film with Michael giacchino who just got
done directing werewolf by night for Marvel
you know not in our you know it's it's a space
fantasy so it's kind of not there's no Earth
necessarily there's a community on a planet a
farming planet and um these uh there's a bunch
of bad guys um the mother worlds armies are in
the area and they need to be fed so they they
come to the village and ask for uh the village to
feed them basically while they're doing their War
yeah in that area of the Galaxy and of course
um they are not uh kind about asking and the
result will probably be the obliteration for the
village and so the villagers decide to fight and
so you know they have to go out into the Galaxy
and collect some soldiers to four years to help
but as he talks about he says that he hopes this
Rebel moon will turn into its own special thing
like its own franchise and do more films after
it he does talk a little bit about his Star Wars
influences there but he's talked about this
in the past as well originally what happened
is about 10 years ago before Disney bought Star
Wars and before he had finished releasing the
first man of steel Superman movie Disney had
started taking pitches for what would become
the Star Wars sequel Trilogy like Star Wars the
Force awakens and he like many other directors at
the time pitched his take to lucasfilm so for a
brief hot second there was a chance that he was
going to make the Snyder verse version of the Star
Wars sequel movies he said his pitch was rejected
at the time but this was back in 2012 when they
said no to his ideas and he says out of that he
took his original Star Wars pitch and took out
the trademark Star Wars stuff the locations of
the characters like Luke Skywalker and the like
and essentially just reimagined everything is the
exact same type of movie same scenario that looked
and moved the same way same basic story in general
just know Star Wars copyrighted stuff maybe with a
Wilhelm screen but that's not copyrighted like no
studio owns The Wilhelm scream and named it Rebel
moon like Rebel as in Rebels from Star Wars but
imagined it as an Endor type of movie like he
mentioned during his interview he hasn't fully
revealed exactly what would have happened in his
Star Wars movies but he said it was meant to be
a darker grittier Kurosawa Seven Samurai type
of film on a planet like Endor which is where
all the Star Wars comes in obviously George Lucas
has said for a long time that the original Star
Wars movies were heavily inspired by Kurosawa
Samurai films like Hidden Fortress so it makes
sense that Zack Snyder would pitch something based
on similar things and after they turned him down
and he took the name Rebel moon in the scenario a
lot of the characters and just took the Star Wars
out when you look at the trailer footage here and
you listen to the synopsis for the movie it does
feel like a very Seven Samurai Kurosawa type
of movie a bunch of badasses get together to
protect a village from a really powerful force
when he says a dark and grittier take on Star
Wars a good example would be his DC movies like
Batman v Superman the Justice League Snyder cut
movies that go way harder just in general than you
would expect in the very specific hyper stylized
look that Zack Snyder gives to all of his movies
but done in Space Opera style I don't know how
things would have turned out if he had wound up
making the Star Wars sequel movies it sounds like
he would have had to lead the DC movies early on
if that had happened because if he was pitching a
Star Wars Trilogy in 2012 before Man of Steel was
out it sounds like at that time his contract to
come back for Batman v Superman and Justice League
hadn't been finalized yet or Warner Brothers was
just waiting out Man of Steel to see how it
would perform financially in theaters before
they hired him back at the time that was all
happening you remember the Slate of DC movies
that they had planned was completely different
that changed a couple times over the years when
they hired him to come back after a Man of Steel
it was for Batman v Superman with the idea that
they had already planned on doing his his Justice
League Trilogy like by the time they hired him to
come back for Batman being Superman they're like
okay we're gonna let you do Justice League now
and that's why they let him do Man of Steel too
as uh Batman v Superman movie instead of just a
straight up Man of Steel 2 sequel like they would
do with most directors because they were trying
to get their Justice League movie out within
a couple years of that and they wanted to get
all the characters together way faster it wasn't
until Batman v Superman was released in theaters
in 2015 that Warner Brothers started messing with
the Justice League Trilogy of movies when Batman v
Superman came out in theaters they were already
deep in production on the first Justice League
movie and critical response was so polarizing
to that Batman v Superman that Warner Brothers
freaked they canceled Justice League three like
they told them that he could only do two Justice
League movies so they had to get all of his story
out in two movies now and a little while after
that they did it again they freaked again and
said he could only do one Justice League movie
and then tragedy struck his daughter died and
we saw what happened next Joss Whedon came on it
turned into a huge debacle for several years cut
to recently he came back to do his original plan
and for the Justice League Snyder cup with a few
minor tweaks and additions because he didn't know
if he'd ever get to come back for more and that's
how we got the Justice League Snyder cut he did
reveal what his full plans were originally for
Justice League sequels two and three I've done
a much larger video for it because there's so much
stuff in there like they would have been huge I'll
post a link for that video in the description
below because it gets just as crazy as you would
expect it to they actually asked him Point Blank
if he's coming back to do more DC movies like have
they contacted you to come back and do more after
the Justice League Snyder cut as he says he has
not been subsequently contacted by any of the
new people at Warner Brothers in DC about the
Snyder versus movies or doing more DC films and
I don't think that he's lying about that like I
think he's trying to basically say no they haven't
said anything to me yet and you have to remember
that I think this interview was happening before
James Gunn was hired by DC so at the time Henry
Cavill still thought that he was coming back as
Superman for more Man of Steel movies Gal Gadot
was still making Wonder Woman 3 they were still
planning on building up to a new movie version of
crisis on infinite Earth a much bigger version
of the one that we saw in the DC TV series but
then James Gunn was hired like a month after that
and elected to reboot pretty much everything not
every single thing like not 100 but like 99 of
it he did say before the end of January he would
reveal the full DC Phase One of movies and we
know that there's going to be a brand new Superman
movie during that because he revealed that he's
actually been writing a new Superman movie with
the younger Superman but recently people saw him
reading All-Star Superman and that is probably one
of the better Superman stories so a lot of people
are like wait a minute does that mean that the new
Superman movie is inspired by All-Star Superman
it sounds like it'll be an original story like
it won't be a direct comic adaptation but I will
do videos for all the big announcements that he
winds up making that should happen pretty soon so
make sure to enable alerts for my channel so you
don't miss those videos we'll probably see the
next big Rebel Moon trailer in a couple months
they're still working on post-production for the
movie there were a bunch of other trailers that
Netflix just dropped I just did videos for
you can click here for my Netflix Avatar The
Last Airbender trailer video in Easter eggs and
click here for my Flash movie alternate ending in
post-credits scene with Henry Cavill Superman
the Justice League a bunch of other deleted
scenes thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!